[Musique]
mais le débat sur france 24 c'est le 21e
jour de guerre en ukraine alors que les
bombardements continus sur les grandes
villes volodymyr et lens qui s'est
adressé au congrès américain en
visioconférence le président ukrainien
interpellé joe biden l'exhortant à être
le leader du monde et de la paix il a
demandé une nouvelle fois la mise en
place d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne au
dessus de son pays une demande jusqu'ici
toujours refusé par jo bats et donne
même si un certain nombre de
parlementaires démocrates et
républicains sont favorables à l'envoi
d'avions militaires à l'ukraine le
président américain a ajouté une aide
supplémentaire de 800 millions de
dollars à l'ukraine il n'y aura pas de
déploiement terrestre et aérien en
ukraine néanmoins de l'otan c'est ce
qu'a affirmé son secrétaire général à
l'issue d'une réunion à bruxelles alors
jusqu'où ira joe biden dans la guerre en
ukraine l'otan va-t-elle changer de
stratégie on va en débattre avec mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
anne toulouse bonsoir vous êtes un
journaliste franco-américaine hauteur de
walk isme la france sera t-elle
contaminés et c'est aux éditions du
rocher c'est sorti le 16 mars bienvenue
à l'ennui est donc aujourd'hui
exactement ça sort aujourd'hui merci
d'être avec nous et léa volochine notre
correspondante de france 24 en russie à
bonsoir et lennar nous avons duplex de
washington christian hanley consultant
politique auprès du parti démocrate
bonsoir à vous et puis pascal boniface
bonsoir pascal boniface directeur de
l'iris
avant cette discussion on va rappeler
justement que volume et volodymyr 0 ce
qui le président ukrainien s'est adressé
au congrès américain un peu dans la
tradition des leaders étrangers qui
s'adresse aux deux chambres aux deux
chambres américaine depuis 1945
churchill mandela merkel ou encore la
reine elizabeth s'était livré à ce même
exercice il à vienne il a fait bien sûr
en visioconférence d'ukraine et il a
projeté une vidéo d'ailleurs de
l'ukraine sous les bombes on peut en
voir un extrait il a montré des enfants
morts blessés c'est extrêmement violent
je ne sais pas si on va pouvoir voir une
partie de ces images
en tout cas zelensky a demandé une fois
encore une zone d'exclusion aérienne on
va l'écouter
nous devons protéger le ciel ukrainien
pour protéger les citoyens et ainsi la
russie ne pourra pas continuer à
terroriser nos villes libres si c'est
trop demander eh bien nous proposons une
alternative
vous savez de quel système de défense
aérienne nous avons besoin
nous
nous avons besoin d'une aviation
puissante pour protéger notre peuple
notre terre notre liberté
ainsi vous pourrez aider les ukrainiens
vous pourrez aider l'europe
pascal boniface zelensky a établi un
parallèle entre la guerre en ukraine et
le 11 septembre
il a invité le président américain être
un leader du monde sait ce qu'il a dit
joe biden va augmenter les aides
financières le matériel la militaire
défensif mais pour le moment aux états
unis on ne décide pas d'envoyer des
avions militaires à l'ukraine à ce qu'il
pourrait céder à un moment donné djaouad
ils ne croient pas et je pense que même
tous les élus républicains et démocrates
réunis qui ont applaudi très
chaleureusement zelensky ne serait pas
prêt à rentrer en guerre pour les
soutenir l'ukraine donc il ya quand même
une fatigue de la guerre aux états unis
et cette guerre serait quand même
extrêmement dangereuse pour les états
unis puisque ça serait une guerre
mondiale contre la russie donc s'ils
utilisent des avions s'est effectivement
il envoie des avions américains ça veut
dire que c'est la guerre mondiale c'est
ce que dit joe biden mais oui puisqu'en
fait il y aurait un risque très fort
d'abattre un avion russe si on veut
faire une zone d'exclusion aérienne donc
c'est pour interdire aux avions russes
de pénétrer sur le territoire ukrainien
et donc il faudra abattre un avion russe
est donc ce sera l'entrée en guerre
officielle des états unis contre la
russie ce que bill downe a voulu éviter
depuis le départ il a même dit très
fortement avant même l'invasion russe
qu'il ne ferait rien peut-être mieux
fait de ne rien dire et de laisser un
peu le doute et une dissuasion et je
vois mal maintenant que la situation
encore plus dangereuse le faire et je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait un soutien au
congrès donc les gens sont très
favorables zelensky ils applaudissent
ils sont prêts à lui envoyer de l'argent
priori des armées qui ne sort pas des
équipements de l'armée
c'est des sommes qui seront fabriqués
mais qui ne seront pas extraite de
l'armée américaine pour lui donner c'est
donc pas une participation directe c'est
une ânerie depuis déjà assez longtemps
les etats unis n militairement l'ukraine
il ya laissé de l'information il ya des
transferts de matériel il ya des aides à
ses importantes qui vont être augmentées
pour faire mal à l'armée russe sans
participer la limite c'est la
participation directe au conflit pour
l'armée américaine christiane là vous
qui travaillez avec les démocrates
justement à washington il ya un débat
tout de même au congrès puisque le
sénateur rob portman par exemple qui lui
est républicain ou encore la démocrate
amy klobuchar eux sont favorables à
l'envoi d'avions militaires en ukraine s
qu'effectivement il pourrait faire
pression sur joe biden
effectivement non en fait c'était un jeu
politique pour certains actes de
parce qu'ils sont républicains il veut
leur embarrassé si vous voulez joe biden
que ce soit ici aux etats-unis ou à
l'étranger que veut dire zone
d'exclusion c'est pas une sorte de tâche
rouge sur la carte du monde non en fait
ça veut dire créer une zone dans
laquelle les avions de chasse américains
doivent devenir des avions de patrouille
ça veut dire que si on crée une zone
d'exclusion il y aura des pilotes
américains qui vont devoir attaquer même
tuer des pilotes russes ce qui veut dire
la troisième guerre mondiale donc ce
genre d'action directe c'est hors de
question pour jour baden pour n'importe
quel président américain et quant aux
sénateurs et aux réprésentatif
républicain ce qu'ils font c'est jouer à
un jeu politique c'est tout oui mais
christiane mais il ya aussi la démocrate
et miquelon bouchard qui demandent
l'envoi d'avions
et il y en a l'envoi d'avions ce n'est
autre question ont envoyé des avions
c'est peut-être possible
même si le président
craignent ce que je viens de dire la dmr
poutine ça veut dire que cet acte
constitue un acte de guerre c'est une
autre question quand même que de créer
une zone d'exclusion ce qui serait un
acte directe de la part des états unis
donc il ya une question là dessus mais
pour créer cette zone c'est pas vraiment
possible pour les états unis pour le
président des états unis poggio byden
parce que on a toujours la russie qui
est toujours un pouvoir nucléaire en
toulouse il ya des républicains
effectivement qui demandent plus sain
qui demande qu'on envoie des avions
militaires aux etats-unis est-ce que joe
biden est trop prudent
je moi je ne suis pas spécialiste de la
stratégie je ne peux pas vous dire s'il
est trop prudent je sais que ce que je
peux vous dire en étudiant son histoire
c'est qu'il est prudent ça n'est pas un
foudre de guerre c'est un homme qui a
été élu sur la promesse de ramener des
troupes d'afghanistan ce qu'il a fait
d'une façon qui a été assez malheureuse
mais qu'il a fait tout de même donc
c'est quelqu'un qui est emmené vers
l'intérieur un des collaborateurs de
barack obama je ne souviens plus qu'elle
disait joe biden dans toutes les
discussions à l'époque où il était
vice-président ramène tout à ce qui se
passe chez lui dans sa ville de scranton
en pennsylvanie
alors je pense qu'un créneau de scranton
en pennsylvanie on n'a pas envie de
faire la guerre mondiale troisième
guerre mondiale je pense que les
américains sont très solidaires de ce
qui se passe en ukraine ils ont aussi le
côté humain horrifie tout le monde comme
partout ailleurs maintenant ils sont
derrière les sanctions évidemment qu'il
leur coûte pas cher d'ailleurs parce que
les états unis sont quand même les
premiers producteurs mondiaux de gaz et
de pétrole et pour pour le reste j'ai lu
un sondage que j'ai trouvé très
intéressante le premier sondage était
une semaine êtes vous favorable à une
zone d'exclusion aérienne et là tout le
monde répond pratiquement tout le monde
répondait oui absolument et puis on
repose le même sondage une semaine après
en disant mais est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à une zone d'exclusion
aérienne avec les conséquences que ça
implique c'est à dire l'entrée militaire
et alors là évidemment tout le monde
répond non elana volochine ce serait une
sorte de lit rouges franchis pour
poutine alors moi je voulais justement
parler des lignes rouges de vladimir
poutine parce qu'on dit si on ne crée
pas de zone d'exclusion aérienne si on
n'envoie pas des avions de l'otan ça va
on ne provoque pas la guerre avec la
dîmière poutine mettons-nous maintenant
à la place de vladimir poutine qu'est ce
qu'ils exigent depuis décembre dernier
vladimir poutine c'est là où il nous a
sorti ses exigences qui sont
irrecevables pour les occidentaux et là
d'où tout est parti il a envoyé ses
exigences aux états unis et à l'otan en
disant vous retirer tout le matériel un
militaire que vous avez un grosso modo
en europe et vous retirer toutes les
troupes que vous avez dans les 13 pays
qui ont intégré l'otan depuis 97 or
aujourd'hui le volodymyr zelensky
demande envoyez-nous encore plus d'armes
pour pouvoir nous défendre de
l'agression russe donc pour vladimir
poutine même ça si vous voulez c'est un
acte de guerre c'est complètement
irrecevable ce que vladimir poutine
c'est que les américains non seulement
cessent de livrer des armes à l'ukraine
mais condé militarise complètement
l'ukraine non seulement des armes
occidentales et américaines mais des
propres armes ukrainiennes c'est ces
conditions à lui pour cesser la guerre
donc la ligne rouge est déjà franchir le
mur rouge de vladimir poutine en tout
cas elle est franchie depuis enfin dans
son discours en tout cas les franchises
depuis longtemps c'est ce qui sert à
justifier son attaque de l'ukraine
pascal boniface pour revenir justement à
cette histoire d'envoi d'aviron parce
que il ya ces fameux mig-29 que les
polonais donc était prêt à envoyer en
ukraine mais à condition donc ils
partent une base militaire en allemagne
à ramstein parce qu'ils ont peur d
envoyer directement il ya tout un débat
autour de l'envoi ou pas de ces livres
encore pour ne pas apparaître comme
étant qu aux belligérants aux yeux des
russes -dont qui avait fait des lignes
rouges qui sont tressés et qui font peur
aux autres et les mannequins ont refusé
cela parce qu'eux-mêmes ne veux pas que
ça parte de base militaire américaine ce
sont des mig-29 donc qui appartient de
l'armée polonaise que les pilotes
ukrainiens savent piloter donc ils
peuvent les adapté assez facilement
parce que si on envoyait des avions
américains les et le pilote ukrainien ne
sa part les mains de vrais crois qu'on
en voit justement ces avions fait dire
que l'on est qu belligérants parce que
ben rappelez vous la guerre iran irak
entre 81 88 la france avait donné prêter
des avions militaires à l'irak et donc
il rend les considérer que par ce prêt
de matériel militaire qui appartenait à
l'armée française eh bien les super
étendard qui avait pilonné des
installations pétrolières
iranienne l'iran a conseillé que la
france était kobe géantes et elles
s'étaient vengés en commettant des
attentats en durant notre ambassadeur au
liban louis delamare et c'est donc en
fait si vous prenez de votre matériel de
votre armée des équipements pour les
mettre à disposition d'une armée
étrangère vous êtes co belligérants en
revanche lorsque vous utilisez des vous
envoyez des équipements ce qu'ils font
pour donc anti sorte d' usine c'est
différent parce que là vous faites des
ventes d'armes c'est la tradition et
c'est assez connu donc effectivement si
vous en voyez les équipements qui
sortent d'usiné qui sont des armes
fabriquées aux états unis fabriqué en
france et c'est là vous n'êtes pas colby
joint aux cieux vous livrer des
matériels qui n'appartiennent pas à
l'armée américaine où l'armée française
donc tout ce débat autour des avions qui
faisait dire également que les polonais
les envoyer leurs avions russes et qu'à
la place est allée récupérer les avions
américains tout ça c'est exclu
aujourd'hui pour l'instant alors
peut-être que là ça pourrait changer
mais même je pense que vous l'avez dit
byden et quand même ultra prudent il ne
veut pas glisser le moindre doigt dans
un engrenage qui pourrait lui ap
l'ensemble du bras giovanna a néanmoins
annoncé aujourd'hui même une aide
supplémentaire de 800 millions de
dollars on va voir justement on va
l'écouter le président américain il
avait déjà signé plus de 13 milliards de
dollars d aide à l'ukraine en l'écoutent
cela inclut 800 systèmes antiaériens
pour permettre à l'armée ukrainienne de
continuer à arrêter les avions et les
hélicoptères qui attaquent les civils et
de défendre l'espace aérien de l'ukraine
nous envoyons aussi des drones pour
montrer notre engagement à envoyer nos
systèmes de défenses les plus
sophistiqués pour aider l'ukraine à se
défendre
christian henn là on a bien vu que
effectivement il s'agissait donc dead
supplémentaires dans tout ce qui était
défensif on a bien vu la distinction
avec pascal boniface zellers qui a
demandé au président américain d'être un
leader du monde sait ce qu'il a dit dans
ce discours effectivement il a une
standing-ovation est ce que joe biden
envie d'être un leader du monde
je crois que franchement dubaï n'a envie
d'être un président en temps de paix en
temps de guerre et donc malheureusement
pour lui c'est son devoir d'être leaders
du monde même s'il veut être président
d'un pays qui a assuré que tu as des
guerres que ce soit en afghanistan en
irak avec une population qui ne veux
plus de guerre est donc pour lui pour
joe biden c'est une obligation
je crois que aujourd'hui avec l'annoncé
d'un milliard de dollars d'aidé
financière peut l'ukraine c'est un
premier étape on va voir s'il va être le
les prochaines étapes mais pour joe
baden maintenant c'est vraiment presque
tout ce qu'il peut faire pour l'ukraine
parce que comme on vient de dire et je
suis pas spécialiste je suis pas enfin
je fais pas partie du militaire mais
comme on voit vous la russie a déjà pour
poutine il ya déjà une ligne rouge
et donc pour pour l'ukraine maintenant
c'est peut-être l'argent la meilleure
façon dans laquelle les états unis
peuvent aider nos amis en ukraine à
toulouse ça va se limiter justement à ça
l'aide à l'ukraine l'aide américaine à
l'ukraine écoutez il y avait quand même
un contraste frappant cet après midi si
vous avez regardé les deux interventions
celle de céline ce qui est celle du
président byden d'un côté vous avez un
homme extrêmement passionnées qui essaie
de soulever les passions américaine qui
cite franklin roosevelt et qui cite
martin luther king qui parle du rêve
durant 2 septembre etc et puis après
vous avez joe biden qui ouvre son carnet
de chèques que peut-il faire d'autre
c'est un président qui a acquis à une
sorte de mauvais sorts contre lui
puisqu'il a été élu il faut dire avec
une coalition extrêmement hétéroclites
qui était composé de la gauche du parti
démocrate
des yeux du reste du parti démocrate et
de tous les gens qui en avaient assez de
donald trump et qui de mon point de vue
sont peut-être une majorité donc il est
obligé de gouverner au milieu de tout ça
sans contrarier personnes pour ne pas
perdre le mid term et on en revient
toujours là haut nous sommes en campagne
électorale aux états unis et donc qu'on
peut pas se permettre d'être romantique
on peut pas se permettre de se lancer
dans des aventures et puis quand vous
regardez le discours de joe biden c'est
évident c'est pas un homme qui valent
aventure tout de même c'est frappant et
pourtant il dit qu'il soutient les
démocraties elena parce que pendant ce
temps là on ne compte plus le nombre
d'arrestations en russie navalni donc
renvoyé dans un camp pendant 13 ans la
répression qui s'amplifie et puis j'ai
vu que les russes avaient riposté aux
sanctions occidentales par des sanctions
peut dire symbolique puisqu'elle vise
jobs hayden manifestement ils ont oublié
robin est donc la porte parole de la
maison blanche disait en fait ils ont
ils ont ce sont des sanctions contre le
père de joe biden est pas joe biden
hillary clinton qui ne peuvent donc plus
se rendre en russie anthony blinken non
plus ce sont des sanctions très
symbolique du côté russe mais en même
temps poutine en faisant cela s'immisce
un peu dans la politique américaine ben
là bon ils sont dans une réponse qui est
symétrique comme d'habitude quand ces
états unis russie retrait des ambassades
sanctions contre les personnalités
retrait du personnel diplomatique va je
veux dire bon là on est vraiment quelque
chose d extrêmement classique on est on
est c'est lui c'est complètement de
l'ordre du symbole évidemment prétends
pas que demain quelqu'un prendra un
avion de washington pour venir en
discuter à moscou fin là évidemment
c'est purement de la rhétorique purement
de la communication qu'est ce que parce
qu'à voler ça parce que effectivement ou
joe biden va s'arrêter là où à ce que
comme on est dans une stratégie tumen de
sanction graduée il peut encore aller
plus loin sur les sanctions à la russie
et qu'est-ce qui peut ajouter finalement
parce que la guerre sera long et il a
dit pour interdire aux pays européens
enfin de me proposer des sanctions
contre les pays européens qui continuent
d'acheter du gaz et du pétrole la russie
mais elle dit viseraient la solidarité
occidentale donc il ne peut pas il ya
quand même aussi en charge d'une union
sa communication autant là le débâcle de
kaboul a été catastrophique depuis
l'essai de se rattraper et de montrer
qu'il consulte qui est dans le
multilatéralisme que les alliés ça
compte etc il est vrai que le fait que
les pays de l'otan soit unie face à la
russie est extrêmement important don qui
lie à leur ai dit qu'ils allaient
justement venir à bruxelles la semaine
prochaine lors de la prochaine session
de l'ordinaire de l'otan il ne veut pas
fissuré ce camp occidental qui tient un
peu bien après ce qu'il peut faire aussi
c'est essayer de rallier au delà du
monde occidental il ya quand même de
nombreux pays qui se sont abstenus dans
la condamnation de la russie à
l'assemblée générale pas beaucoup mais
une quarantaine donc il faut un peu
faire cela peut pas compter sur la chine
déjà mais disons que la chine si ce
qu'il peut voir c'est jusqu'où la chine
ne peut ne pas aider la russie est donc
la chine est dans une position on très
délicate puisque ils n'ont pas envie de
voir la russie s'écrouler ils n'ont pas
envie de dire que les sanctions ça
marche parce que c'est vraiment
contraire toute leur politique mais ils
sont très mal à l'aise avec le geste
aventuriste de poutine qui vient
déclenché une crise économique ils sont
très consommateurs d'énergie et de
produits alimentaires ce sont les deux
produits qui augmentent le plus donc ça
peut créer une crise économique ou du
moins un ralentissement économique à la
chine ce qui les rend vraiment très peu
à l'aise avec cela donc en fait le but
de bayonne devrait d'élargir la
coalition anti russe et moins il
apparaîtra va-t-en guerre puis il pourra
élargir cette coalition christian
ouellet vous êtes d'accord à ce que
vient de dire justement pascal boniface
et sanction symbolique d'ailleurs il ya
eu des réactions
aux états unis et alors qu'on est
effectivement à quelques mois des
midterms et son essai sanction
symbolique contre hillary clinton joe
biden et même hunter by john le fils
ils n'ont pas du tout ici non comme vous
venez de dire ce sont des sanctions d'un
complément symbolique y a pas besoin
pour hillary clinton the bad and allez
voyager en russie d'aller rendre visite
à moscou maman non ce sont comme vous
dites complément symbolique écouter la
russie est un pays qui maintenant à une
économie
moins diversifiée - mois large moins
puissante que même dans quelques états
individuels des états unis à une
économie plus petites que celles de la
californie du texas et donc pour eux ils
ont pas vraiment le pouvoir économique
de mettre en place des sanctions qui
sont très utiles ce seront toujours des
actes symboliques
elle égrène ici à gauche - comme on en
parle est-ce qu'ils ne craignent pas une
ingérence des russes tout de même dans
les élections
vous n'êtes pas que je vois ici aux
etats unis à washington aujourd'hui non
non pas du tout ne pensez pas qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
non moi je pense que aux etats unis
c'est vrai que les sanctions sont vécus
comme symbolique parce que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure le pays étant un
grand producteur d'énergie ça ne m'a pas
les toucher et ils ont un mal
mal à comprendre moi qui a un pied dans
les deux pays j'ai vu par exemple quand
je suis parti en france il ya deux
semaines jean cluzel a battu c'était
presque si j'allais me mettre dans la
gueule du loup si j'allais sur la ligne
de front parce que finalement entre
paris et washington y ait la même entre
paris et kiev il y à la même distance
qu'entre washington et denver pas pour
eux c'est très pressé c'est un autre
porte ils ont aussi beaucoup de mal à
comprendre que effectivement parce
qu'elle parlait de sanctionner les pays
européens qui achètent de l'énergie
russe mais comment peuvent-ils faire
autrement se dire qu'il ya des pays
comme l'italie est comme l'allemagne qui
sont totalement dépendants de l'énergie
russe et je me souviens même qu'au mois
de novembre joe biden au moment où il ya
eu une petite crise énergétique aux
états unis à cause des rues des suites
du coc vie des ruptures
d'approvisionnement et tout ça avait
demandé à la russie d'augmenter sa
production de gaz pour fournir les pays
européens faut quand même être un peu
logique dans cette histoire et lennar
vous dire à quel point ces sanctions
sont symboliquement on est on est dans
la guerre froide entre moscou et
washington depuis un certain moment
l'année dernière quand vladimir poutine
et joe biden se sont rencontrés à genève
après l'élection de joe biden il était
question de faire revenir les
ambassadeurs en poste et de voir comment
est-ce qu'on allait pouvoir renouer tous
les canaux de dialogue tous les canaux
de dialogue qui ont été rompues au cours
de toutes ces dernières années donc
aujourd'hui en sanctionnant joe biden et
hillary clinton s'est juste on sait on
sait plus où frapper bon bah voilà on va
rompre adopter des sanctions comme ça
pour dire que on est contre les états
unis était question d'ailleurs de
limiter la cyberguerre à l'époque oui
non mais complètement mais c'est à dire
que là aujourd'hui tout est tellement
tout est tellement énorme et on est
tellement dans une dans une guerre
froide qui risque de devenir une guerre
chaude que on ne peut plus que frapper
comme ça symboliquement au plus haut
sommet de l'état et puis il ya une
réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'otan aujourd'hui joe
biden donc il se rendra à bruxelles un
ce que je disais la semaine prochaine et
il n'y aura pas de déploiement terrestre
ou encore aérien en ukraine de l'otan
mais un déploiement de davantage de
troupes de moyens sur le flanc est de
l'alliance on écoute son secrétaire
général
bon les alliés sont unis pour apporter
un soutien à l'ukraine
pour que les ukrainiens puisse se
défendre sauf qu'aux fins mais les
alliés partage aussi une autre position
commune l'otan ne devrait pas déployer
de force sur le terrain dans l'espace
aérien une craignent ans
parce que nous avons une responsabilité
veillez à ce que ce conflit cette guerre
ne s'étendent pas au delà de l'ukraine
est-ce qu'elle boniface même ligne rouge
là du côté de l'otan oui enfin il est
rare que ce rachat vient le temps
tiennent un discours très différent de
celui du président des états unis
généralement ils sont quand même raccord
donc effectivement là il confirme qu'il
ne déploie pas de soldats de l'otan en
ukraine parce que ces soldats pourraient
être pris pour cible par l'armée russe
et se défendre et donc là ça serait la
guerre donc effectivement on est dans la
même ligne c'est rien dans le ciel
aérien sur terre par rapport à l'ukraine
et on masse autour de l'ukraine pour
envoyer comme signal à la russie ne
touchez pas aux pays de l'otan parce que
la donne a été par contre très précis
que le moindre centimètre carré de d'un
pays de l'otan qui seraient attaqués par
la russie la défendre et à garder la
ligne rouge côté occidental est ce que
ça veut dire véritablement que les
américains enverrait un missile en
russie c'est effectivement un missile
touchait la pole alors c'est pas les
représailles massives c'est pas
forcément un missaoui un missile non
nucléaires effectivement willoughby ci
ne serait pas tout de suite la guerre
nucléaire mais effectivement les propos
de biden au son très clair si un pays de
l'otan et attaquer l'article 5 seront
mis en oeuvre qui prévoit une surdité
automatique des autres pays donc ce pays
serait défendue par les différentes
armées des pays de l'otan pour venir sur
ce court contre l'armée russe joe biden
serait prêt à le faire à toulouse on
pensait je pense jamais à la glaciation
assez comme le disait pascal c'est
l'application d'une règle d'un traité
donc je vois pas comment il pourrait
après avoir appelé à la cohésion à la
solidarité de l'otan aux forces
d'européennes ne pas respecter les
règlements même là si c'est un
automatisme et une apologie vous pensez
que vladimir poutine le sait ça et que
justement il se limite il fera attention
ça c'est vraiment une bonne question je
ne sais pas du tout s'il va se limiter
au parc de la préserver visibilité de la
lia autre chose c'est que très
franchement ce que montre l'armée russe
et qu'elle n'est pas très performante
c'est à dire que c'est quand même une
armée qui ne marche pas très bien
puisqu'ils ont du mal à battre l'ukraine
qui est quand même un pays qui est pas
très bien équipé militairement qui n'est
pas très riche qui avec un pib est très
faible et c'est donc quand vous avez du
mal à battre l'armée ukrainienne vous
attaquez pas ou 30 armées des pays de
l'otan avec en soutien l'armée
américaine mais le problème c'est qu'il
est donc pardon à mon avenir et
peut-être dans une logique où il a pas
grand chose à perdre on n'a pas encore
peut-être joué toutes ses cartes non
plus côté russe par ce qu'il y a un gros
contingent qui est en ukraine qui en
ukraine mais il ya aussi un conte en
compte engendre qui est encore prêt à
rentrer en ukraine donc il y a une force
de motivation d'un côté ukrainien mais
une force de frappe juste physique parce
que tout le budget la défense de ces
dernières années en russie a été tout le
budget de l'est de l'état fédéral ces
dernières années en russie a été
réorientée à la défense et donc on a des
armements dernier cri on a une force de
frappe juste militaires qui étaient
extrêmement puissante donc oui il ya le
manque de motivation des hommes il ya le
manque logistique mais je pense que les
difficultés auxquelles est confrontée
l'armée russe potentiellement elle
pourrait être résolu en cours de route
en réajustant la stratégie en réajustant
le commandement je serai prudente avec
ça et je serai aussi prudente avec le
fait de dire que vladimir poutine a
surestimé sa force et qu'il n'attaquera
jamais ou même ne ferait pas tombée par
erreur un missile dans un pays de l'otan
pascal boniface augmentation fin très
franchement je sais bien qu'il a commis
une très grave erreur de jugement là
quand l'ukraine en sous-estimant les
forces ukraine et surestimant les
siennes propres mais l'ukraine est une
chose l'otan et une autre où delà de
l'aspect de l'article 5 sais que c'est
un plan la puissance rien que les pays
européens de l'otan ont des dépenses
militaires de 250 milliards les dépenses
militaires russes et 60 milliards donc
plus les états unis là je pense qu'il
n'est pas suffisamment irréaliste pour
se permettre d'attaquer l'autre à la
même chose qu'il n'attaquerait jamais
l'ukraine et qui n'iraient jamais
spectacle moi c'est tout ce que je dis
je ne sais pas qui va le faire je dis
simplement qu'il est comme vous le
disiez complètement imprévisible et que
on sait pas il faut revenir à ses
motivations au final christian elle
laisse que les états unis effectivement
si jamais la meilleure poutine franchit
cette ligne rouge volontairement ou non
volontairement est ce qu'il y aurait
sept articles 5 est ce que les
américains donc un qui sont commandement
de l'otan le véritablement riposterait
souviens quand même de barack obama en
qui je crois france en syrie
c'est lui mais la première ligne rouge
en syrie ce n'était pas une vraie ligne
rouge
légal historique avec une longue
tradition entre alliés comme la ligne
rouge
dans l'europe de l'est pour les pays de
l'est les pays membres de l'otan écoutez
la semaine dernière vers la fin de la
semaine jeudi vendredi on n'a eu qu'à
malades ce qui faisait le tour de
l'europe de l'est qui était à varsovie
avec le président de la pologne qui
étaient en roumanie aussi et qui a dix
qui a dit plusieurs fois que les états
unis étaient prêts toujours à défendre
chaque centimètre carré du territoire
des pays membres de l'otan ça veut dire
la pologne la roumanie et tout l'europe
de l'est l'europe centrale donc
aussi si on vient d'envoyer notre
vice-président à varsovie à l'europe de
l'est
pour faire cesser et promet je crois que
ça va être la politique de cette
administration pendant la durée de cette
guerre en ukraine oui à toulouse ils le
feraient ils riposterait je continue à
poser la question parce qu'effectivement
barack obama avaient parlé fixé une
ligne rouge à en syrie on s'en souvient
en disant que si assad utilisez-les
armes chimiques et bien il y aurait une
intervention américaine et finalement il
n'y a pas eu d'intervention à méribel là
ça n'était pas dans le cadre d'un traité
international et ça faisait partie vous
savez je sais plus qui a dit en france
que les promesses n'engagent que ceux
qui les reçoivent et là effectivement il
ya eu de nombreuses lignes rouges qui
ont été franchies sous barack obama est
qui et qui sont restées
lettre morte parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'engagement formel de le faire parce
que vous avez parlé de l'opinion
publique américaine qui suit pas
forcément favorable à ce que la balle
opinion à carrick américaine n'a aucune
envie de s'engager dans une guerre
aucune et d'ailleurs la différence c'est
qu'eux en syrie les stasi n'était pas
directement concerné c'était une
intervention une guerre civile et donc
il y avait un engagement verbal
effectivement monsieur men engagement
verbal important souvenez vous à
l'époque oui m'enfin c'est pas vrai qui
sait pas c'est pas un traité est surtout
là ce sont les intérêts des états unis
qui seraient affectés s'il ne répondait
pas à une attaque russe contre des
troupes alliées c'est tout à fait
différent que de répondre à un crime de
guerre commises par l'armée syrienne où
les saisies ne voulait surtout pas
s'engager au proche orient il cherche à
se désengager il dégaine de subir des
désagréments en irak et donc barack
obama très bien dit qu'il avait été élu
pour mettre fin aux guerres pas en
commencer une nouvelle et narac on a
l'impression qu'il y va à reculons la
job hayden et d'ailleurs depuis le début
de l' attaque russe moi j'ai eu
l'impression que il était assez absent
finalement et on peut le comprendre
parce que depuis depuis un certain temps
et depuis qu'il y avait cet
accroissement militaires aux frontières
du craignent n les européens disaient
nous on veut être de la discussion sur
notre sécurité les français les
allemands poussé pour que soient les
allées les européens qui reprennent en
main leur destin sécuritaire et au
moment où on s'attendait à ce qu'ils
aient une réaction forte des états unis
au début de l'invasion russe eh bien on
a surtout entendu emmanuel macron les
européens prendre position et venir en
aide à l'ukraine finalement là c'est
quand même l'entrée dans l'entrée dans
le jeu indé américain comment on est 21e
21e jour de guerre effectivement donc on
a l'impression qu'il a une question de
ligne rouge et qu' il n'y aura une
réponse forte qu'à partir du moment où
effectivement ils sentiront directement
menacés alors si on parle justement des
armes chimiques parce que la maison
blanche et on a parlé à plusieurs
reprises pascal boniface qu'il y aurait
peut-être une utilisation par la russie
d'armes chimiques en ukraine alors là je
repose la question est ce que c'est une
ligne rouge si effectivement vladimir
poutine utilise l'armé chimique en
ukraine s qui aura riposte occidental
oui parce que enfin disons que là ce
serait une violation supplémentaire d'un
traité normalement la russie a signé un
traité qui lui interdit non seulement
d'utiliser même de posséder un éphèbe
bachar al assad n'avaient peut-être pas
signé manteau cacher la salle l'a signé
après les russes rappelez-vous dans
l'épisode où barack obama a tracé ni
rouge qui n'a pas respecté les russes
sont intervenues et ont demandé aux
syriens de signer ce traité
d'interdiction des armes chimiques qui
n'avait pas signé auparavant le premier
art chimiques c'est que c'est l'horreur
absolue c'est cette addiction juridique
une erreur morale c'est pas ça qui
arrive poutine ce qui veut plus
s'arrêter poutine c'est qu'en fait c'est
pas un gain militaire extrêmement
avantageux c'est ne donne pas une super
8 et militaires s'affaireront risettes à
terroriser les populations sur en syrie
effectivement il va déjà plus de deux
cent mille morts de la répression de
bachar lorsqu'elle des armes chimiques
et l'utilisation d'armes chimiques n'a
fait que 1000 morts supplémentaires si
j'ose dire a créé beaucoup plus
d'émotions que les deux cent mille
premiers morts de la répression de
bachar al assad donc là on atteint
effectivement ça terrorise complètement
les populations ça terrorise les
diplomaties et là effectivement ça
serait de la part de poutine se lancer
dans une aventure sans retour parce que
là il n'y aurait plus de portes de
sortie possibles là il ya encore une
porte de sortie pour lui suffisamment
chimiques il n'y a plus de porte de
sortie possible on peut pas l'exclure
alors moi je parle sous votre contrôle
il me semble que la russie n'a jamais
utilisé dans une situation de guerre
d'armes chimiques en non pas pour le mon
allié bachar al assad oui mais les
russes non blancs et d'ailleurs la
position de rue c'est de dire qu'on ne
possède plus d'armes chimiques le novice
chaque par exemple il y dément un poison
jaillit des logements raison les je
donne un exemple de qui parle aux gens
et de dans l'histoire tout à fait
récente loi pose et demande alexeï
navalni avant cela de ces règles et
skripal mémo aux novices choc une arme
un poison de guerre qui a été prouvé
qu'il existe puisqu'il empoisonné à
l'excès navalni et sergueï skripal mais
dont la russie dit nous ne possédons pas
c'est pareil avec les armes chimiques
donc il n'y met enfin oui mais c'est à
dire concernant on peut pas leur faire
confiance sur le fait la confiance et ça
ils peuvent très bien avoir une capacité
d'armes chimiques qu'ils ont planqué qui
échappe que des inspections enfin et
d'ailleurs c'est relativement facile
parler de la syrie de bachar al assad
les russes entre autres disaient voilà
il ya tant d'armes chimiques qui ont été
détruites il y d'abord king ils
démentaient le fait qu'il ya eu des
attaques chimiques du côté du régime
syrien ensuite ils disaient voilà nous
sommes dans le processus de contrôle du
fait que la syrie détruit ses stocks
d'armes chimiques etc c'est du lala la
russie il faut bien comprendre qu'elle
est dans une position où sa défense
c'est un secret d'état elle ne dévoile
jamais ni ses capacités réelles ni son
budget réel nice et sa stratégie jamais
donc on ne peut pas savoir réellement et
en syrie à une inspection de l'aviation
internationale du contrôle de ce traité
qui a était venu vérifier la destruction
de l'arsenal chimie de bachar oui
exactement et la russie devaient aussi
participer à ce contrôle il n'a pas
empêché dont bachar el-assad de
l'utiliser christian hanley les états
unis d'ailleurs ont affirmé qu'il y
avait des possibilités que vladimir
poutine utilise l'armé chimique en
ukraine
j'espère que non mais c'est vrai que
personne ici à washington fait confiance
à à
la russie à vladimir poutine et comme
nous autres invités viennent de dire ce
sont des secrets d'état donc on sait pas
vraiment ce
que sont les la russie en tant que
capacités
s'il existe toujours des armes chimiques
en russie selon c'est ici à washington
c'est que vers les murs poutine et la
russie vient d'annoncer qui a peut-être
des attaques chimiques qui viennent de
l'occident est typiquement ce que ça
veut dire c'est que la russie est en
train de
mentir la public pour pour
pour cacher peut-être un plan quelque
chose qu'ils vont faire dans l'avenir et
donc et c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
d'armes chimiques des taxes imitait la
part de la russie ici à washington
aujourd'hui ce sont des
[Musique]
annonces
largement diffusée dans les médias en
russie c'est pour ça à toulouse c'est
vrai qu'il ya presse américaine parle
d'éventuelles utilisations par vladimir
poutine d'armes chimiques
oui bon il est toujours soupçonné du
pirée c'est vrai que il ya le la
dimension imprévisible il ya même vous
savez que joe biden avait
encore plus une détestation particulière
pour vladimir poutine pendant sa
campagne électorale il a traité
d'assassin on lui a dit est ce que vous
pensez que c'est un assassin il a
répondu oui et il raconte très
volontiers puisque c'est un homme qui a
en quelque sorte est toujours dans le
narratif de sa propre histoire que quand
il l'a rencontré pour la première fois s
qualité vladimir poutine au kremlin et
s'était à l'époque où il était
vice-président il l'a regardé et il lui
a dit je regarde dans vos yeux et vous
n'avez pas d'âme alors il doit le pense
et encore plus aujourd'hui c'était une
référence à georges bush qui lors de la
première rencontre avait dit j'ai
regardé dans ses yeux j'ai vu son dame
donc il y avait déjà au départ c'est un
homme que joe biden qui n'a pas une
grande constance dans sa politique
internationale c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire est dans ses opinions sur la
politique internationale en a toujours
une c'est qu'il ne pouvait pas souffrir
vladimir poutine et qu'il s'en méfier et
aujourd'hui de se dire qu'il a bien
raison pascal boniface est ce que
effectivement pour revenir sur le sujet
s comment est ce que les états unis
pourraient intervenir c'est
effectivement il y avait une utilisation
de cette arme chimique
solution c'est durcir encore les
sanctions économiques mais non la rive
un peu au bout ou prendre la sio de
rentrer en guerre et il n'est pas
certain et qu'il le fasse malgré une
saison l'art chimiques parce que la sas
reddition assez lourde et peut-être même
au contraire qui se dira est décidément
poutine est prêt à tout on n'a pas
intérêt à se lancer dans une guerre
contre lui donc là il ya vraiment mais
une fois encore l' avantage militaire de
la rue chimique n'est pas aussi évident
que cela elle peut se retourner contre
vous les vents peuvent être contraire et
c'est donc pour l'instant poutine peut
continuer à détruire l'ukraine sans
recourir aux armes chimiques s'il le
faisait ces qui aurait décidé finalement
de couper tous les ponts avec le monde
occidental et de se lancer dans une
fuite éperdue son retour il ya 800 euros
s'il ya une chose aussi avec la volonté
ou non par la russie d'utiliser
éventuellement larmes chimiques c'est
que par exemple quand effectivement joe
biden avait répondu à cette question
journalistes en disant oui à la question
est-ce que vous pensez que l'asie
mineure poutine est un assassin vladimir
poutine avait répondu c'est celui qui
dit qui est sauf qu'elle a dit mr
poutine c'est celui qui dit qui fait
donc la dîmière poutine qui accusent
sans cesse les à craignent les
ukrainiens de crimes de guerre on
prétend aujourd'hui de quel côté sont
les crimes de guerre c'est pareil avec
le pilonnage des couloirs humanitaires
et ce serait éventuellement pareil avec
une halte à 40 chimiques c'est à dire
qu'il est tout à fait possible n'exclus
pas le scénario ou demain vladimir
poutine utilisent leurs armes chimiques
et que sa propagande dise voilà les
ukrainiens sont responsables d'une
attaque chimique et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment qu'il serait dans
la ligne directe de ce que fait le
régime de poutine donc c'est vraiment
pas exclure parce qu'effectivement il
pourrait instrumentalisé servir à cela
aussi c'est pas exclure en disant
effectivement disant qu' il a été fait
du côté de des ukrainiens mais en
protégeant d'une muse disons qu'il doit
quand même être déjà être en difficulté
là ils jouent un chapitre encore plus
difficile si le fait une fois encore
j'insiste là-dessus l' avantage
militaire n'est pas aussi important que
cela alors l'autre chapitre c'est le
nucléaire effectivement donc à ça c'est
encore un autre un autre autre
possibilité bladimir poutine pascal
boniface pourrait-il effectivement
utilisé des armes nucléaires alors il ya
tout un débat la biélorussie maintenant
est sorti de sa constitution sa
neutralité pour effectivement oui en
fait il n'a pas besoin de déployer des
armes nucléaires en biélorussie pour
pouvoir attaquer donc là il se lance
effectivement dans l'armageddon parce
que là du coup tout devient
incontrôlable c'est simplement la
destruction donc s'il de moscou qui est
en jeu s'il se lance dans une attaque
nucléaire alors est ce qu'il est devenu
complètement cinglé et que plus rien ne
le retient il ya quand même des
procédures heureusement si elle que même
si poutine tout d'un coup y atteint par
un virus mortel et qui se dit j'en ai
marre j'ai tout faire péter avant
d'aller au paradis il ya quand même des
procédures qui font que il n'a pas le
doigt sur le bouton et qui va pas se
réveiller furax en disant toc il n'est
pas ce que vous dites elena volochine on
parle beaucoup de sa paranoïa
effectivement et au final il serait pas
seul totalement à prendre ce type de
cette décision alors ça c'est un grand
mystère aujourd'hui c'est à quel point
est-ce que vladimir poutine est seul
dans cette campagne dans tous les cas ce
qui est certain c'est que son ministre
de la défense est riche et ce goût c'est
tout simplement le bras droit ils sont
ils sont comparés voilà c mais les deux
les deux bras d'une même d'une même
machine gay chevaux qui manifestement a
changé
avec quelqu'un qui était peut-être plus
libérale à une époque non je ne pense
pas que c'est le goût a changé tout
comme je ne pense pas que vladimir
poutine et de la changer ou je pense que
c'est nous qui avions sous-estimé ce qui
se passait ce qui se passait en russie
avant que ça explose actuellement aux
yeux du monde maintenant sur le scénario
d'une attaque nucléaire ou ou pas
je pense que ces voix là qu'il faut
qu'il faut juste être un petit peu
humble et observer ce qui se passe parce
que on ne l'a pas été on a pas on n'a
pas vu venir l'ampleur de cette attaque
et
on en était à faire des scénarios qui
ont qui se sont tous révélés bien en
dessous de ce qui sépare les
renseignements américains mais parler
quand même d'une attaque sur kiev
possible ils avaient laissé fuiter dans
la presse d'ailleurs tout cet ensemble
d'informations oui effectivement
maintenant la question c'est de savoir à
quel point est-ce que cela tout cela se
prépare et très longtemps à l'avancé ou
durant ces derniers mois il n'est pas
exclu que ce que ce que cela se prépare
et même bien avant encore que le
renseignement américain en ai parlé mais
c'est vrai qu'après on a toujours
sous-estimé on disait en 2014 que non il
ne serait pas la crimée récemment on
disait que non il n'en attirait pas
l'ukraine maintenant à dire non il
n'utilisera pas d'armes nucléaires moi
je pense que la hausse à doulon et moi
je suis pour la position simplement
d'humilité d'observation et d'analysé
très concrète au jour le jour de cette
guerre et de ce qui se passe sans faire
de pronostics sur qu'est ce que voudrait
faire de la dîmière poutine jusqu'où il
ira et c'est parce qu'on ne peut pas se
ramenait pas non plus vous vous posez la
question est-ce qu'il est sous sol on
peut pas se baser sur ce qui se passe
dans son entourage parce qu'on n'en sait
rien c'est l'opacité totale il n'y a
rien qui fuitent déjà à la base là que
l'âme mois pour qu'ils travaillent en
russie la russie n'est pas une pays où
il ya la culture du off c'est à dire où
on aurait des conseillers ou des hommes
politiques qui nous dirait des choses à
nous journalistes qui ne serait pas
caméra non les murs du kremlin est ce
qui se passe dans le bureau de la
dernière poutine dans l'entourage de la
demi-heure poutine s'est vraiment on n'a
pas d' inside là dessus on peut pas
savoir christian elle l'est pour
justement faire un dernier tour de table
on va revenir justement à joe biden qui
va donc venir à bruxelles la semaine
prochaine l'idée c'est quoi c'est encore
de dire à l'europe enfin à l'otan on est
tous ensemble et de dire aux européens
soyez plus autonome
et toujours unis
oui en fait non c'est si oui c'est pour
renforcer
unification de l'occident autour de
cette attaque en ukraine par la russie
et puis si pour montrer que ce que fait
les états unis c'est ce ne sont pas
simplement des actes symboliques ce sont
des actes réels même si notre
participation dans cette guerre est tout
de même un direct donc pour indiquer que
le la maison blanche sera toujours siège
d'un livre du monde gévrise émane
parisienne et puis pour montrer aussi
qu' il y a toujours le soutien du peuple
américain même si le peuple américain a
pas envie de de participer à encore une
autre guerre
qu'on est toujours là en tant que
intrants d'allier et qu'on est là avec
un un peu de soutien financière et du
soutien au niveau de l'équipement des
armes envoyées en europe donc oui c'est
à la fois un acte symbolique mais
également à un acte visite qui souligne
le soutien vrai et crée elle même si un
direct de la part des états unis à
toulouse c'est vraiment l'allié des
européens aujourd'hui joe biden dans
cette guerre et côté de toute façon
c'est son intérêt joe biden a intérêt à
endosser les habits que l'ue attend du
président céline ski c'est à dire de
leader du monde libre quelque part ça
arrange son image de marque parce qu'il
n'était pas dans une très bonne position
sur le plan intérieur et là d'un seul
coup ça lui donne une stature qui ne se
traduit pas trop dans les sondages mais
c'est ça assène 60 n'ont pas vraiment
léger a pris un ou deux points il est
autour de 40 ce qui en français bien
mais aux états unis c'est pas terrible
et donc là il va quand même se
se présenter comme le président du
leader du monde libre et puis en même
temps il peut mettre une certain à
certain nombre de problèmes intérieurs
sur le dos de la crise ukrainienne par
exemple l'inflation alors l'inflation
déjà au mois de novembre c'était 6% moi
de au début du mois de janvier c'était 7
% on en est à 8 je pense qu'il ya de
l'inflation même sens que poutine s'en
mêle mais maintenant ça devient
l'inflation de poutine de même que le
prix de l'essence qui augmente
maintenant c'est l'augmentation de
poutine bon quand j'ai quitté les états
unis elle était déjà à quatre dollars ce
qu'il le gall 1 pour 4 litres c'est
énorme aux états unis si ça vous ferait
rêver mais mais voilà donc ça permet les
problèmes extérieurs sont toujours bond
quand on a des petits problèmes d'image
intérieur à quelques mois des élections
mettant une conclusion en pascal
boniface justement sur weiden à
bruxelles la semaine prochaine c'est le
grand vainqueur de cette crise parce que
on disait l'otan état de mort cérébrale
maintenant tout le monde célèbre l'otan
et tout le monde demande la protection
du grand oncle américains y compris la
finlande peut-être ces pays qui
pourraient adhérer à l'otan ainsi que la
suède effectivement parce
qu'effectivement quelque chose de très
différent merci beaucoup christiane
l'air d'avoir été avec nous merci pascal
boniface merci anne toulouse merci et
les nord elena volochine merci à vous
tous nous avoir suivi et le tallec
comprend 24
[Musique]